hot breath yeah and how how has this
sobriety affected your comedy
uh it's how everything that's happened
you know
like all the big things that happened in
my career happened sort of in sobriety
like
opening for louie and then i got to do
letterman i had a half hour special and
um or the half hour whatever it's called
and i got to do conan all that stuff
sort of came in sobriety working at the
comedy seller all that stuff headlining
having a manager an agent all that stuff
came in sobriety
for me it definitely turned everything
around
for me um because i feel like i was a
talented guy and doing pretty well you
know i had
work and i think people respected me or
whatever
but it took kind of sobriety like all
right let's focus and try to really
do this and work it mm-hmm um for me
personally because i was always a mess
dr
i'm not a guy there's a lot of comedians
that um
there's like a or there's a sort of this
um
thought that uh or aura that these
comedians are all like
painful and struggly and depressed but i
couldn't work like that i'm i do i write
and
i'm more productive when i'm happy and
feeling good which happens a lot more in
sobriety than it did in drinking for me
so it's definitely helped me
creatively and professionally it just
helped all my relationships which
benefits your career
did it help like did you have goals at
the beginning of comedy or when you got
sobers when you're like okay i want to
do letterman i want a
comedy central yeah that was a big thing
and tommy john again was a guy that
really helped me with that as well like
setting goals because the only goals i
ever set for myself
were like i would like to be a comedian
in boston like to be a boston comic and
then eventually move to new york
and then work the road so i accomplished
all of those things which was another
like epiphany in sobriety that i was
like well i've actually accomplished
everything i've ever tried to do
i just haven't tried to do that much
right yeah so it became a thing of like
let me do letterman i'll just decide
that i was like let me try to do this
thing
and then i was able to do that so then i
was like all right what do i want to
that sobriety allowed me to go what do i
want to do what would i like to kind of
be
and let me work towards that as opposed
to just being like let me just try to be
a comedian
which um if your goal is to just be a
comedian that's not hard you can just
go to a show an open mic or whatever
right
um not that it's easy but just to be a
whatever any comedian is not all that
difficult